i want you to close your eyes for a
moment and imagine the house that you're
sitting in cut in half that's exactly
what a section is and that's exactly
what i'm going to show you today in
archicad 25. okay so in the last video
we talked about elevations and we left
it relatively simple now we're going to
introduce sections into our
documentation and basically split our
building in half to understand the
construction and the fine details of
what's going on now there are generic
section markers set up in archicad that
we can move across and utilize so let's
say we want to cut through that door and
window and we also want to cut through
that window there and the roof the
section markers are very similar to the
elevation markers the section is
indicated at the top s02 is the section
itself and a400 is the page you'll find
it on that it has been placed on if that
bottom half of the marker is not visible
or is blank for any reason then you need
to put your sections onto the layout
book to be able to actually activate
that marker automatically if we start
with the very basics going section zero
one clicking into section zero one we'll
see that we have cut our building in
half we can see our slab here at the
bottom we can see our walls we can see
our roof structure our windows and our
doors if we start changing elements of
this structure we could understand and
be able to actually differentiate the
different systems so if i click command
t on this
slab we can change that to a concrete
finish let's say tile floor and we'll
see that automatically update now i do
have my true line weight pen tool turned
on and that's why we can see the
differentiating factors of the dense
dark lines compared to the lighter lines
in the background if you want to change
that view on screen view true line
weight off and now we'll get a better
understanding and a clearer vision of
what's going on as you can see arcad is
very very good at picking up the
differences so it knows exactly where
the tiles stop hard against that wall it
won't continue that tile all the way
across or the street all the way across
but it will continue that concrete slab
because that's how it would be built if
i was to click on this wall for example
it is just a generic wall now a generic
wall won't really be very useful to us
in any construction detail so let's
change that in this instance to a 150
brick veneer wall and we'll see a vast
difference now there are traditional
methods to showcase brick and timber
which is automatically depicted in
archicad if you use the correct template
for your region i'm going to drag that
wall now back up to the top go to my
ground floor plan locate my slab and
move that to the edge of my wall so if i
move that back 110 mil come back into my
section one we'll see the slab stops in
line with the edge of the brickwork now
again there are multiple ways that we
can do this next step the easiest way is
to simply grab the fill tool use our
generic fill drafting fill concrete and
draw in our extended slab thickening now
this is in a details video in any way
shape or form it's just showing you a
generic section and how we can
manipulate the elements as you can see
this window is now sitting directly over
and above our timber frame and leaving
our air cavity between the timber leaf
and the brick leaf completely exposed so
if we click on not
the roof if we go available t we can
change that roof to relatively simple
rbc insulated battens click ok and we'll
get once again a completely different
roof structure shown now in a section we
can go through a lot more details we can
start using the detail marker tool so if
we select that detail draw our square
and click ok it'll create our first
detail next we'd probably want our
windowsill detail our window head detail
our connection from top to toe and they
would be our four details indicated on
this page just that one section which
would need to be very clear very well
articulated and very well annotated if
we then wanted to find one of these
detail markers we could simply click on
this detail marker open with current
view settings and it would take us
directly to that detail marker now that
detail marker we could change the scale
down to bottom potentially to a 1 in 10
scale so we can detail that very very
heavily and actually articulate what we
need to show we could show insulation in
our cavity if we needed it we could
return the plasterboard up the top we
could do a significant amount of
architectural detailing to this one
individual section
now be very very careful that once you
start annotating and marking up this
detail if anything changes in the
architectural 3d section it will not
automatically update in a detail because
the detail is still 2d in archicad so
for instance if we go back to our
section and let's say we move that
window back to
zero reveal
and our cavity was completely exposed
come back in to detail too
we would see that isn't updated until we
right-clicked on detailed view and went
rebuild from source view
that's when we would see our entire
parameters change and if anything is
linked anything is connected to one of
these fills it will completely mess up
your detail and you'll have to start
again so just be very wary that if you
do one of these detail drawings you do
them at the very end when you know
nothing further is going to change
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash the like button down
below and don't forget about the
subscribe button if you want to check
out links in the description there are a
number of useful resources down there as
well as always i will see you next
monday